Wir hören jetzt das Podcast Urufow, das Podcast Urufow, Florentin und Stefan am Mikro, sie sitzen am Mikro, heben ab und landen auf Pluto, sie landen auf Pluto, und jetzt noch viel Spaß bei der Show, viel Spaß bei der Show. Tim Featuring, der hat's erkannt. Äh, Dennis. Nein, Tim Featuring, Johan Sebastian Back, he's back. Ah, okay. Und er hat uns ein paar Klänge aus dem Barock mitgebracht, das war Tim ganz wichtig, der hat das extra in der Mail dazugeschrieben. Featuring Johannes Sebastian Back. Ich hab mich da ein bisschen inspirieren lassen bei The Big B und deswegen führt er uns diese Klänge vor, die vielleicht schon in Vergessenheit geraten sind, aber nicht für Tim, er revivet sie nochmal. Er revivet sie, er hat JB Beck zurückgebracht, Jace Bay. Jo. Jace Bay. JB Bay. Ja. Und ich finde es ja ganz klasse, weil Bach war ja damals auch schon so ein bisschen der Hip-Hopper seiner Zeit. Das sagen alle. Das sagen alle. Weil ich finde, er hat hier wirklich eine Brücke geschlagen über die Zeit und deswegen ganz, ganz viele Grüße an Tim, ganz, ganz toll gemacht. Ich glaube, dafür ist Bach ja bekannt, also für seine Fugen und dafür, dass er Hip-Hop, den modernen Hip-Hop, wie ihn jetzt kennengelernt hat. Quasi, er hat ja, ich glaube Hip-Hop, er hat auch den gemacht, ne? Ja. Das war auch Bach, glaube ich. Bisschen später, auch Deutschland, bisschen später und nicht so feierlich. Das stimmt, ja. Okay, aber das stimmt, also er hat Fugen, weißt du genau, was eine Fuge eigentlich ist? Ich habe einige Fugen analysiert in meinem Leben. Ich weiß nur noch, dass Fuge steht für Flucht. Und dann habe ich im Unterricht gesagt, ja, kann ich verstehen, werde ich auch lieber für dich. Tatsächlich war es so, es war tatsächlich so, dass aus irgendeinem Grund gab es zwei Parallelklassen und alle meine Freunde waren irgendwie in der anderen und ich habe den sprachlichen Zweig genommen und viele meiner Freunde hatten einen anderen Zweig, die hatten Musik und ich hatte keine Musik mehr. Und das heißt, ich hatte Freistunde, während alle anderen Musik hatten und oft habe ich mich einfach Freistunden-Hack. Ja, ich habe sogar weniger Freistunden gewollt, weil ich habe mich dann zu meinen Freunden in die Musikstunde gesetzt und saß dann dabei, hab keine Noten bekommen, war einfach nur anwesend und war dann einfach so ein bisschen der Sassy Guy, der Sassy Guy, der Rüpel. Und ich hab auch alle Klassenarbeiten mitgeschrieben, aber halt nur Nonsens. Aber ist man nicht erstens viel schlagfertiger, viel besser, wenn es um nichts geht, du bist wahnsinnig cool, sitzt da in der letzten Reihe, dir kannst ein bisschen egal sein, aber du willst natürlich auch irgendwie, also du hast irgendwie, glaube ich, dadurch, dass du, es ist wie so ein Fallschirm, den du über dir hast, es ist völlig egal, was passiert, und dadurch, wahrscheinlich warst du sehr gut in dem Fach, bestes Fach, beste Noten gehabt? Ich sag mal, ich bin, hab mich sehr selbstbewusst gemeldet, und das war aber jetzt auch der Musikunterricht, der jetzt nicht so hardcore war, sondern wo Noten durch Singstar vergeben wurden. Ach der grünte Singstar-Kurs.
An der Hand von Amy Winehouse, sag ich mal, mich zu eins gesungen habe auf jeden Fall.
Welcher Song?
Rehab.
Und dann muss man sich einen Lehrer auch vorstellen, der gesagt hat, so und die nächste zensierte Arbeit kommt von Florentin mit der Startnummer 13.
Amy Winehouse, Rehab. Wenn alle anderen Schüler sich denken, ich hasse Musik. Aber so habe ich auch. Ich hasse Musik einfach. Ich will nie wieder was mit Musik zu tun haben. Ich weiß noch, früher war ich noch ganz klein. Meine Eltern haben... Was ist früher kleiner? Ich war ganz, ganz klein damals noch, früher, und dann sind meine Eltern, haben lange gearbeitet. Und dann hatte ich so Nannies, die auf mich aufgepasst haben. Mehrere? Mehrere Nannies über die Zeit, verschlissen. Und zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte ich eine Nanny, die mit mir Zingsta immer gespielt hat. Und dann haben wir das zusammen gespielt und sie war leider sehr gut. Oh dann meinen, ich glaube es war Eternal Flame oder sowas, hat sie, das war der beste Song von mir und da hat sie einen besseren Score gehabt. Dann irgendwann, meine Eltern kamen nach Hause, sie geht nach Hause und dann habe ich den ganzen Nachmittag und Abend versucht, Eternal Flame besser, eine bessere Punktzahl bei Eternal Flame zu bekommen als meine Nanny, was dazu geführt hat. Und ich war, man kennt das natürlich, wenn man halt so jagt, man merkt auch, das Zeitfenster wird immer kürzer. Gleich kommt TV-Totale und muss ins Bett. Immer wenn das kam, war vorbei, 2015, Spongebob vorbei, ins Bett. Und das Zeitfenster kam immer näher, auch gleich Essenszeit auch noch, da wird mir auch noch was gestohlen von der wertvollen Zeit, die ich habe, um Eternal Flame besser zu singen als sie. Und irgendwann war ich super wütend und habe da so angefangen, basically so vor Wut, so Rage, blass zu werden und so Tränen. Ist auch kein Genuss, kein Ausdruck, nur Close your eyes, give me a win, darling. Und dann direkt schon gemerkt, do you fee, do you fee, ah, hier fehlt mir was. Fuck! Genau. Okay, nochmal, fuck, und dann fehlt mir da, ich hab schon gemerkt, da fehlt mir jetzt was und dann schon in der ersten Strophe ausgemacht, Playstation neu gestartet, geht wieder los, Stecker raus, Stecker rein, du kannst das stecken und dann immer so, fuck, fuck, jetzt heust dich mal zusammen, ich hasse mich, du bist nichts wert, du bist nichts wert, and eternal faith, und dann irgendwann ging es nicht mehr ums Singen, es ging nur noch darum, die Töne zu treffen, diese Balken zu treffen. Und dann wurde es wirklich, wie du auch gerade nachgemacht hast, sondern hm hm hm hm hm hm hm. Weil ich hab, weil, dir stehen Konsonanten im Weg. Ja, absolut. Dir stehen Konsonanten und die Lyrics stehen dir als, weiß ich nicht, neun Jahre altem Kind im Weg. Die Sprache, die du nicht sprichst, machen dir den Punkt kaputt, die Punkte-Score.
Ach, es war eine harte Zeit. Ich weiß noch, ich habe einmal den perfekten Score hingekriegt mit dem Kumpel von mir von Cascada, Cause Every Time We Touch.
Ja, anstrengender Song.
Bis heute den Song, wenn der kommt, wirklich alle so, walk out cause every time we touch und nicht nur so.
Drei, zwei, eins, vier, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch, hoch so ... Drei, zwei, drei, zwei ... Ja, Florentin, alle am Tanzvoll, ich komme dann an mit so nem Wasser, was ich besorge und mache dir das ins Gesicht.
Florentin, hey, alles gut? Hast du zu viel getrunken, hast du zu viel Radler getrunken?
Ich dachte, ich krieg den Einsatz nicht bei Takt 15.
Hey, Entschuldigung, ich war auf dem perfekten Score.
Hey, wir mussten dich raustragen, du bist nicht mehr im Club, wir mussten dich raustragen. Du bist so unmächtig geworden, so Cascadas, Everytime We Touch. Ich bin in der Pembinenstock. Wo habt ihr mich hingetragen? Nein, nein, wir sind nach Hause. Nein, wir sind nach Hause gegangen. Ach so. Hey, alles gut. Du warst super lange raus. Es tut mir leid, es ist Dienstag. Wir waren Samstag aus. Sorry, dieser Song, der, ich will ihn perfekt machen. Every Time We Touch von Cascada, er ist schon in der Originalversion nicht perfekt, ehrlich gesagt. Hä, alles gut? Es ist alles ... Ich habe ihn einmal perfekt gemacht und ich glaube, ich werde es nie wieder schaffen. Aber ich weiß noch, Singstar war für mich der Moment, wo ich das erste Mal, also ich weiß nicht, in jedem Leben, glaube ich, gibt es, und für viele Menschen ist der Punkt noch nicht gekommen, in jedem Leben gibt es den Moment, wo man merkt, ah ja, ich habe ja gar keine Ahnung. Zwei, zweimal. In jedem Leben gibt es zweimal den Moment, wo man merkt, was keine Ahnung. Ach jetzt, ich habe ja überhaupt gar keinen Plan. Jetzt verstehe ich's. Und das war bei mir, als dann irgendwie wir Singstar gespielt haben und ein guter Kumpel von mir ist auch im Chor und mega gut in Musik, das ist auch einer von den Geierchor-Sängern. Und der kennt sich halt mega gut aus. Und dann hören wir uns diese Singstar-Songs an. Da gibt es so einen Song, wo die Stimme so verändert ist, wo die so ein bisschen computermässig dann klingt. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, es ist irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Und dann habe ich so gesagt, ja, ich finde das irgendwie, keine Ahnung, das hat für mich nichts mit Singen zu tun, weil das ist ja alles nur Computer. Habt ihr euch vor Singstein eine musiktheoretische Diskussion verstrickt? Genau, und dann meinte mein Freund, naja gut, aber die Töne musst du ja trotzdem treffen. Und ich so, euer Freundeskreis. Ach, ich hab, jetzt verstehe ich's, ich bin das Problem. Ja. Ich bin dumm. Ja. Nicht irgendwie die mit ihren Computer, die machen sich sehr leicht. Nee, ich habe keine Ahnung. Und seitdem habe ich nie wieder was gesagt. Nie wieder ein Hot Take. Das war mein einziger Hot Take. Seitdem nur noch Cold Takes. Ich schwank hier zwischen geiler Freundeskreis, irgendwie weirde Ideen und so. Und the sassiness. Ich komme darüber nicht hinweg. Die Sprüche, die du raushaust manchmal. Dann auch Dadpan-Kumpel, der dann einfach auch sagt, du bist das Problem. Einfach im Keim erstinkt, so diese Stammtisch-Mentalität, so das ist doch keine echte Musik mehr, das ist doch nur noch Computer und Autotune, du musst die Töne ja trotzdem treffen. Viele wissen nicht, dass Florentin perfekt bayerisch gesprochen hat, bis sie im Moment, wo er im Club von Kaskada, die Back-Eat-The-Dance-Float umgekippt ist und dann wieder aufgewacht ist. Ich war ein anderer Mensch danach. Ich habe mein komplettes Gedächtnis verloren zu dem Zeitpunkt. Ja, aber du bist froh, dass du vorher nicht so viel erlebt hast. Nein, es gab einen zweiten Punkt, wo ich immer wieder daran denken muss, Snowboard-Kurs und dann machst du einen Snowboard-Kurs für Anfänger und nächstes Jahr machst du einen Snowboard-Kurs für Fortgeschrittene und der Snowboard-Kurs für Fortgeschrittene Leiter, der Snowboard-Lehrer, das Erste, was er gesagt hat, so, ihr seid jetzt im Fortgeschrittenen-Kurs, ich will, dass ihr alles vergesst, was ihr über Snowboarden wisst. Ich habe gerade, hast du das nicht in der letzten Folge erzählt? Das habe ich dir privat schon erzählt. Das habe ich dir privat schon erzählt. Okay, Gott sei Dank, weil ich dachte gerade, wie lustig wäre das, wenn du ausgerechnet diese Story.
Vergess alles, was du hier gelernt hast, was du jemals gesagt hast, was du diese Story jemals erzählt hast. Es war so gut, weil ich so als Elfjähriger da stand und dachte, Moment, okay, jetzt, ich vergesse jetzt, also ich weiss eh nicht viel über Snowboards, aber ich liebe diese Figur des Snowboardlehrers, der so kommt wirklich bei so Zwölölfjährigen, die einfach Schnee essen und sich gegenseitig mit Schnee bewerfen, eine stecken mit dem Kopf im Schnee und dann so er war der Typ, der den Anfängerkurs macht, er macht Snowboard 1.1.1 und ich glaube, die haben ihn eingeteilt für den falschen Kurs.
Ach, das kann auch sein, ja. Und ich glaube, er kam schwitzend dahin und dachte mir, fuck, fuck, fuck, 15-12-Jährige, die jetzt mit mir in gelben Westen, diese 12-15-Jährige? Mann, ich habe das Briefly nicht gesehen. Das blieb mir nicht gelesen, ich finde es lächerlich schlecht vorbereitet. War schwarze Piste das gefährliche oder blaue Piste? Ich weiß es nicht. Wir stehen hier an einer schwarzen Piste mit 15, 70, 70, 15-Jährigen und ich musste jetzt irgendwie den Berg runter bekommen und ich kann nur den Anfängerkurs machen, okay? Ich sag denen clever, vergesst alles, was ihr im ersten Kurs gelernt habt.
Aber das zu Kindern zu sagen ist auch so dumm, weil...
Das zu Kindern zu sagen ist so geil, weil dieses vergesst alles, so in jedem Kurs, so Töpferkurs.
Okay, bevor wir anfangen, ich will, dass ihr alles vergesst, was ihr über das Töpfern wisst.
Hä, aber ich kann schon kleine Verzierungen und Religi...
Ich will, dass du alles vergisst.
Alles bis Töpfern.
Wir sind bei Null.
Wir sind bei Null. Okay. Okay? Also. Nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nne, nts, rückwärts, seitwärts. Und wenn du mit dem linken Fuss, und es gibt zwei Arten von Snowboardfahrern, die meisten fahren mit dem linken Fuss vorne, Regular. Moment, Moment, Moment, ist das nicht so ein Rechtshänder-Linkshänder-Ding? Es gibt Überschneidungen, aber nicht identisch. Links vorne Regular, rechts vorne Goofy. Okay, also wir sehen, wir sind hier in einem coolen Rennen. Hier will ich nicht auffallen in der Gruppe und will deswegen Regular. Das sind solche Entscheidungen in meinem Leben, wo auch wenn ich da ein schlechter wäre, ich will nicht jemand, der Goofy f sein. Und die Art, weil du es gerade sagst, links in den Rechtshänden, wie findest du es raus, und zwar was Snowboardlehrer machen, ist die sagen einem Kind, mach mal einen Liegestütz. Oder machst du einen Liegestütz, es geht nicht wirklich um den Liegestütz, es geht darum, mit welchem Fuss du dann als erstes aufstehst. So, und den Fuss, den du als erstes sozusagen nach vorne ziehst, um aufzusteigen, das ist dein starker Fuss. Und Harry Potter steht da und sagt, bitte nicht Goofy, bitte nicht Goofy, bitte nicht Goofy. Nicht Goofy, sagst du also, obwohl ja Goofy die Auserwählten oft sind, die besonderen Kinder, und ich habe das Gefühl, du bist ein ganz besonderer Snowboarder, Harry Potter. Bitte nicht Goofy, bitte nicht Goofy, mach bitte Slack aus, bitte, mach Slack aus. Ich soll also Slack ausmachen, sagst du, Harry Potter. Das muss ich mir noch mal überlegen. Man kann mit dem sprechenden Hut auch über alles reden. Man kann auch alles überreden. Man kann erst mal über alles reden. Wurde er noch für andere Sachen benutzt, ausser für die Hauseinteilungung, wurde er auch benutzt zum ist er so der Counselor. Nee, gar nichts, nee. Ich dachte mir, vielleicht ist er so der Schulpsychologe, weißt du? Ja. Der setzt sich da rein und der liest ja alle deine Gedanken, oder nicht? Liest er alle deine Gedanken, ist das die Idee, nein? Anscheinend schon oder die Wünsche oder Hoffnung, da weiß ich nicht genau. Du bist nicht so richtig drin, dafür, dass du alle Bücher neunmal gelesen hast. Hätte man nicht Snape einfach den Hut aufsetzen können und sagen, sag uns, ob er der Böse ist oder nicht? Nee, hätte man Snape nicht mit diesen Adlern direkt in den Schicksalswerden werfen können. Warum haben die nicht mit diesen Hippogreifen Snape direkt da reingefahren, um den Todesstern zu zerstören? Weil da gibt ja diese Klappe. Hätten die Snape nicht in diese kleine Klappe werfen können? Momentin, du sollst aufhören zu trinken. wenn du trinkst, erzählst du so einen Unsinn über... Auf jeden Fall, ich habe den Liegestütz nicht geschafft. Darum ging es ja nicht. Ich habe mich als dickes Kind mit dem Liegestütz abgemüht und darum ging es gar nicht. Während ich noch weiter Käse von Lüge ich komme nicht hoch und! Und dann meinte er, ja, ja, warum, was ist das? Naja, und dann fährst du mit dem falschen, bist du heute mit dem falschen Fuß Snowboard gefahren? So sagt man ja auch. Wenn du dann so genervt nach Hause kommst, abends. Das Gute war, ich habe ja dann noch den nächsten Kurs gemacht und da habe ich wiederum alles vergessen. Also da war eh wieder alles weg. Also es ist immer so alles komplett neu. Ich finde das so gut. Vergesst vom Kinder. Als hätt ihr entscheiden können, ah okay, genau, dieses Rechtskurvische, bla bla bla, was ich gelernt habe drei Monate lang. Lehn dich gegen den Hang weg. Ja, kleiner Alert war auch schon vorher weg. Diese Information war auch schon vorher nicht mehr klar. Jesus. Das ist schwierig. Du kannst es nicht aktiv vergessen, aber ich meine, die Natur ist grausam. Also ich meine, ich habe heute, ich saß heute wieder ein bisschen im Park und habe wieder ein klassisches Eichhörnchen gesehen. Und seitdem ich weiß, dass Eichhörnchen ihre Nüsse vergraben und dann vergessen, wo die sind, sehe ich Eichhörnchen einfach anders. Weil Eichhörnchen dachte ich immer, die sind flink. Aber mittlerweile denke ich, die sind einfach nur ... Du denkst, die vergessen, die haben die ganze Zeit den Phase von vergessen. Eigentlich wie ich, wenn ich aus der Tür rausgehe und dann meine Taschen abgrabe, habe ich Schlüssel und Hände dabei. Ja genau, so sind die ... Ich meine, wie grausam kann die Natur eigentlich sein, dem einzigen Tier, das seine Nahrungsvorräte an verschiedenen Orten versteckt, bei dem zu sagen, dem geben wir mal ein ganz schlechtes Gedächtnis. Warum haben sie noch mal den Elefanten das gute Gedächtnis gegeben? Weil er nichts versteht, muss sich eh nichts mehr. Der muss sich nie was merken, der ist riesengroß, der ist unverwundbar, der muss nichts wissen. Wohingegen das Tier das alles vergräbt, nichts vergessen, ich meine, das ist... Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment. Ich weiß, das ist unsere Achillesferse, aber Evolution, kurz nochmal, wir holen uns nochmal kurz dieses Buch heraus. Vergesst alles, was du über Evolution wisst. Okay? Okay, wir vergessen jetzt kurz alles, was wir, und das ist sehr viel, über Evolution schon kennengelernt haben. Ist es so, dass Eichhörnchen das vergessen, weil die Natur das braucht? Geht ja nicht. Dann müsste, guck mal auf mich so eindringlich anzugucken. Oder hat haben die Pflanzen
die Vergesslichkeit des Eichhörnchens zu Algen
gemacht oder umgekehrt?
Das kann sein, weil die Pflanzen profitieren
davon, weil die müssen dann sozusagen,
das ist so eine Art künstliche Befruchtung, die brauchen
nicht diesen Vogelweg, diesen klassischen
Rambazamba
Baumweg, wenn du
verstehst, was ich meine.
Normale Fondpflanzung ist ja immer so
ui,
wie mit Pollen und so.
Und wer
darauf jetzt, sag ich mal, keinen Bock hat, der kann
ein Eichhörnchen sagen, so hier, nimm
meinen Samen, pack den
mal irgendwo hin, so, und dann wächst der da auch
wieder. Dadurch wachsen ja auch viele Bäume,
das ist ja gut, aber die Frage ist natürlich,
wer profitiert davon am meisten?
Machen die Bäume
absichtlich schwierige Verstecke? Die Eichhörnchen
Vielen Dank. Dadurch wachsen ja auch viele Bäume, das ist ja gut. Aber die Frage ist natürlich, wer profitiert davon am meisten? Machen die Bäume absichtlich schwierige Verstecke? Die Eichhörnchen, ich glaube, es ist das Schlimmste, wenn du so als Eichhörnchen... Wie sind die Loser, das ist ja die ganze Story. So als Eichhörnchen, du setzt dich so vor den Fernseher, die neue Serie, oh neue Staffel, Last of Us, Let's Go. Oh scheiße, wo sind meine Nüsse? Schatz, hast du schon wieder deine Nüsse vergessen?
What? Oh nein, ich hab... Oh, ich trottel.
Oh, ich trottel, das kann doch nicht wahr sein.
Wir haben im Schrank noch welche. Wir haben im Schrank... Okay, ich will hier diesen Film gucken.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Schatz, es kann nicht dein Ernst sein. Wo hast du die alle hingelegt?
Ähm, ähm, die waren...
Gib mir eine Sekunde. Sag mir meinen Namen, wie heiße ich? Wie ich heiße? Ähm ... wie ... Le ... So, das war's. Nein, nichts mit Le. Sorry, ich kann nichts dafür. Du hast so ein schlechtes Gedächtnis. Ich habe einfach das schlechteste Gedächtnis, tut mir leid. Erinnerst du dich noch an unser allererstes Date? Hey, komm rein, kann ich dir ein paar Nüsse anbieten? Ja, klar, gerne. Okay, ich hab... Ach, du hast keine Nüsse. Nee, nee, nee, ich hab welche, ich muss, warte mal. Sie ist direkt genervt, sie ist direkt genervt. Alle würden sagen, das ist doch kein Problem, du hast keine Nüsse, okay. Aber das ist auch so. In der Vase, überall, nichts, aber sie sind ja, haben ja trotzdem noch geheiratet. Ja, aber wie ist das so passiert? Ich will alles dazwischen sehen. Ja. Draußen wird offenbar gebaut, was ihr immer nicht hört, mit dem man die sehen, wenn man was draußen ist. Ein konstantes Drö ist. Ein konstantes Drönen. Ja, aber es stimmt. Also ich weiß nicht genau, wie das passiert ist. Also inwiefern sich da die Bäume, die vergesslichste Eichhörnchen zu eigen gemacht haben, weiß ich nicht. Ich finde, sind Pflanzen auch super gruselig. Ja genau, sind die Tiere die Chefs der Bäume oder die Bäume die Chefs der Tiere? Also was ist die Hierarchie? Also ich weiß, dass Bäume meine Chefs sind.
Ja, absolut.
Bäume sind definitiv meine Chefs.
Die haben einfach das Sagen.
Die haben das Sagen, die haben die Pollen, die machen mich krank.
Gerade jetzt im Sommer, wenn ich Schatten will, muss ich mich nach den Bäumen richten.
Klar, die fallen auf mich drauf im Zweifel.
Fucking verschwenderisch auch Bäume.
Also ich denke jetzt auch wieder so nachhaltig und so ist ja gerade ein großes Thema.
Bäume interessiert es in Scheiss einfach. Die sagen, oh was, Winter, alle Blätter weggeschmissen, auf dem Boden, einfach runter, fuck it, die ganzen Blüten, Pollen, hau ab, weg damit, einfach runter und fällt alles runter und alles voller Zeug. Es ist noch viel radikaler. Pollen, werden alle abgesondert, um sich zu verbreiten. Aber es muss eine Milliarde Bäume, genau wie ich, muss es auch geben. Tschüss, ganz viele Pollen weg, damit die alle im Herbst, alle, am liebsten nicht von den ganzen Boden voller Blätter, voller meiner Blätter haben. Alles voller Blätter. Ich liebe Ahorn. Es ist eine riesige Umweltverschmutzung. Patriotisch eigentlich. Muss es sein, können die nicht die Blätter irgendwie so zusammenfalten und dann irgendwie in die Hosentasche stecken oder so fürs nächste Jahr, wie so ein Zelt, dass du das dann so zusammenklappst und dann einfach einsteckst? Ist es nicht gut für den Boden? Ist es nicht gut für den Boden? Ja, das ist ja wieder der Stefan Tietze, der sagt, ja, aber in meinem Mülleimer lebt ja ein Waschbär und ein Frettchen, das gehört ja auch zur Natur.
Da sage ich, nein, so funktioniert das nicht.
Okay, wie funktioniert das?
Die Natur macht sich alles zu eigen, aber das heißt trotzdem nicht, dass du sie schlecht behandeln darfst, ja?
Nee, wir reden ja von Bäumen, die ihre Blätter abwerfen, das ist ja wieder zu Kompost.
Ja, aber können die nicht, ja, aber können die das nicht einfach einpacken, haben die einen Rucksack?
Können die das nicht lassen, ist deine Frage.
Können die das nicht irgendwie in den Rucksack tun?
Oder dass es halt zurück in die
Packung oder wo auch immer die die herkamen
dass sie es halt einfach zurücklegen in den Schrank stellen oder so
Okay, Hot Take, Bäume sind
schuld, Bäume sind die Klassenumwelt
Verschmutzer, weg mit Bäumen
Pro, pro Argument
machen aus CO2
das Bessere, das Bessere
das wie ich finde
beste Gas, das beste Gas auf der anderen Seite ist natürlich auch die Frage, wenn dann so ein Nadelbaum kommt. Ey, du hast ein Blatt verloren, Kollege. Okay, hier sind noch drei. Hier, ich lasse noch vier fallen. Warum schmeißt du denn deine Blätter weg? Weil mir alles scheißegal, der Punkt soll voll sein. Hier noch neun, zehn Blätter. Hey, hey, hey, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, warte mal, ich heb hier, du hast Blätter verloren. Was machst du denn? Warum fallen deine Blätter ab? Mehr Blätter weg. Hä? Fuck this, fuck this planet, fuck you. Was soll das denn? Fick dich mit deinen dreckigen Nadeln. Hä, aber warum, es ist doch total dumm, wenn du die Nadeln, wenn du das jetzt abwirfst, musst du die später wieder nachwachsen, das ist ja mega viel Energie. Oh, was passiert hier? Oh, es fallen noch 19 Blätter herunter.
Das ist doch Quatsch. Jetzt machst du jetzt nur, weil ich das was gesagt habe.
Ja, genau. Wenn du weiter mit mir sprichst, je pro Minute, in der du mit mir sprichst, lasse ich 38 Blätter auf den Boden fallen. Wie unvernünftig kann man denn sein? Was ist denn da los? Ahorn, Team Ahorn. Ach Gott, ey. Nadelbaum? Guck mal, alles da. und dann die
so
meterweit geschossen einfach. Und Allergie, Stefan steht daneben, wir so Frisbee spielen und dann plötzlich so es ist so schlimm, Allergie ist so scheiße. Aber deswegen, vor allem war ich neulich in der Apotheke und wollte jetzt mein altbekanntes Reactaktin-Duo wiederhaben. Keine Werbung. Doppel. I just love it. Duo. Genau, Cetirizin drin, was gegen Allergie hilft, aber sehr müde macht, mit Pseudoephedrin, was keinerlei wirkliche Wirkung gegen Allergie hat, wo ich immer so denke, wie geil seid ihr denn? Einfach, es macht mich wieder wach. Pseudoephedrin, baller dich nach vorne. Yes, geil. Das ist auch was in Aspirin-Komplex drin ist, was ich liebe. Warum ist es Pseudoephedrin, ist das nur so? Weil wenn, so geil, das ist zu, Ephedrin wird zu geil, weißt du? Also Pseudoephedrin ist so the good stuff, aber es ist so, es ist so die, es reicht schon. Also kann nicht irgendwann mal der Apothekerverband an die Presse gehen und sagen ... Ja, ist an. Ich habe es doch gerade ... Haben Sie nicht gesehen, wie ich es angeschlossen habe? Alle Medikamente sind Placebo. Vielen Dank. Ähm ... Ja, bitte? Ähm, Rainer von der ... Also mit Nachnamen von der Süddeutschen Zeitung. Ich habe es vermutlich, habe ich mich verhört, aber Sie haben gerade gesagt, dass alle Medikamente Placebos sind. Ja, es ist immer noch an. Check, check, eins, zwei, drei. Vertrauen Sie mir gar nicht, Sie haben gesehen, wie ich die aufgebaut habe. Check, check. Vertrauen Sie mit null? Ja, alle Medikamente sind Placebo. Es ist alles nur Tic Tacs. Tic Tacs? Again, es ist an. Ja. Das wäre so gut. Es ist alles einfach nur Placebo. Das wäre so gut. Es ist alles Placebo. Aber ist Quatsch. Ah, weiss man nicht. Wenn Pseudoephedrin, vielleicht ist es sogar der Apotheker-Sprech für Placebo. Ah, das finde ich gut. Pseudoephedrin.
Na, ein bisschen zu eindeutig.
Ein bisschen zu schlecht kaschiert wäre das dann.
Fake, Fake-Ephedrin.
Das hilft mir immer sehr. Ich hätte noch gerne neun von dem Fake-Ephedrin.
Ja, das Fake-Ephedrin?
Das hilft immer mega, da habe ich keine Allergie mehr.
Okay, alles klar.
Ich bin voll fit und irgendwie geht es mir gut.
Okay.
Genau, Fake-Ephedrin. So ein riesiger Beutel. Ja, wie Kinder, einfach so nichts. Mit so einer Schaufel. Mit dieser Metallschaufel kannst du einfach so, nimmst du nicht so viel, wie Sie wollen. Ja, okay. Okay. Also es hilft auf jeden Fall. Und das haben wir jetzt ausverkauft, weswegen ich ein anderes Produkt bekam von einem Apotheker, der mir gesagt hat, irgendein anderes. Hinten im Rückraum ist einfach nur ein riesiger Kanister mit weissen Pillen und du kriegst einfach irgendwas. Alles das Gleiche, alles Placebo-Stoffe. Immer wenn Verkäufer auch Verkäuferinnen sagen, ja gut, ich gucke mal hinten im Lager nach, stell mir vor, wie sie hier nach hinten gehen und erst mal bei mich lachen. Erst mal lästern, fünf Minuten.
Hast du gesehen, hast du Schuhe von dem gesehen?
Und der ist so gross, er ist angestossen an der Decke.
Was ein Idiot, was ein goofy Idiot.
Und auch so, Helga, kommst du mal bitte?
Und dann gehen sie wieder raus und sagen, nee, wir hatten es nicht mehr. Wir haben es leider nicht mehr in ihrer Größe, in ihrer Halsgröße. Wir haben es leider nicht mehr in ihrer Größe. Es gibt manche Peelen, die müssen genauso groß sein wie der Hals, damit sozusagen der ganze Schleim mitgenommen wird. Ah, okay. Und müssen wir einmal ihre Halsgröße messen. Okay. Ja, okay, ich könnte alles mit mir machen, was ihr wollt. Und dann haben sie mir ein neues gegeben und dann kam ein Machen ein raus, weil ich es nochmal haben, weil es so gut gewirkt hat, weil es ach so gut gewirkt hat. Und da bin ich hin und gesagt, ja, das ist ja das gleiche wie Reaktin-Duo und dann meinte der Apotheker, nee, das ist ein ganz anderer Wirkstoff. Also es ist halt kein Allergie, Antialerikum drin. Helga, kommst du mal bitte? Der Kunde hier hat gerade gesagt, dass das das gleiche ist wie Pseudoeffedrin. Und beide gehen kurz ins Lager und lachen sich kaputt. Das war so, hat er mich einfach verarscht.
Was ist eigentlich dein Job, Helga? Ich werde immer nur gerufen, wenn Leute lachen wollen.
Wenn Leute lachen gerne zu zweit. Hey, Team Helga ist ein guter Job.
Wenn Leute dich immer nur anrufen oder was von dir wollen, damit du sie besparst.
Ja, gut, nämlich jeder braucht eine Helga in seinem Leben und wir haben natürlich einige Helga. Und Scheiße, wenn Leute dich immer nur anrufen oder was von dir wollen, damit du sie besparst. Ja.
Gut, nämlich.
Jeder braucht eine Helga in seinem Leben und wir haben natürlich einige Helga mit dabei.
Und zwar, du erinnerst dich wahrscheinlich, wir haben letztens im Podcast eine Frage gestellt und die Hilfe der Community erbeten.
Klar, weiß ich das noch. Kannst du noch mal kurz sagen, worum es geht?
Ja, wir haben viele Fragen gestellt, also zum Beispiel, warum sind Strassen alle schwarz, warum sind die nicht weiss oder grün wie Rasen, passt sich dann auch, dann sieht alles vielleicht schöner aus. Das war eine große Frage. Wer hat eine andere Frage, ich gebe dir den Hinweis, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, smoke on the water, smoke on the water, was ist das eigentlich, was soll das eigentlich bedeutende, was ist Musik? Was ist Musik, ja. Und da hat uns unsere liebe Hörerin Katja geschrieben. Liebe Grüße. Und zwar schreibt die. Hallo Florentin und Steffen, in der Folge 361 fragte Stefan wieso, als es um Smoke on the Water ging. Also warum ist da Rauch auf dem Wasser? Tatsächlich habe ich dazu Infos aus zweiter Hand. Ein Bekannter von mir und meinen Eltern, mittlerweile Anfang siebzig, ging damals in der Schweiz auf ein Jugendinternat. Er und eine Gruppe von Mitschülern wollten eines Nachts heimlich runter in die Stadt, das Internat lag eher weiter oben auf einem Berg, vermute ich, auf dem Weg runter entdeckten sie dann ein Feuer in der Ferne. Handelte es sich dabei um ein brennendes Casino in der Nähe. Jetzt der interessante Teil. Zu dem Zeitpunkt sollte die Deep Purple dort einen kleinen Auftritt haben, der durch den Brand aber nicht stattfinden konnte. Neben dem Casino war ein Fluss und darauf schimmerte der Rauch des Feuers, was die Band zu dem bekannten Song Smoke on the Water gebracht hat. Das war das WDR 2 Zeitzeichen. Also ein Bekannter von ihren Eltern hat das brennende Casino gesehen, Rauch vom Casino auf Fluss. Fluss, fluss, geht über den Fluss. Rauch auf dem Fluss. On the water. Den Fluss entlang? Ja, okay. In Flussrichtung oder in Gegend, das ist dem Rauch egal. Das wissen wir nicht. Vielleicht. Nee, auf der Nordhalbkugel gegen. Und da hat die gesagt, oh nein, jetzt können wir kein Konzert machen. Big Smoke on the Water. Ich finde cool, dass du das alles noch mal erklärst. Du erklärst mir das alles noch mal. Welch ein fucking Vollidiot. Ich wollte es noch mal zusammenfassen, weil ich finde es fantastisch. Und alles natürlich unbestätigte Spekulationen, ist klar. Vielen Dank, Katja. Nee, aber ich glaube, das stimmt. Weil ich meine auch mal gehört zu haben, dass sie inspiriert wurden von einem Brand und sowas. Das macht ja alles Sinn. Das klingt fantastisch. Vielen Dank für diese tollen Infos. Ich fände es richtig gut. Ich frage mich nur, warum das Casino gebrannt hat. Hat da jemand versucht, also war das so eine Art Ocean's 13 Nummer, wo die ja auch das Casino schütteln, damit die alle rausgehen. War das so eine Art, also ist nicht auch vielleicht Ocean 13 genau an dem Tag entstanden, zwei brillante Kulturgüter unserer Welt, die wir uns nicht mehr wegdenken können. Ocean 13 und den Song Smoke on the Water. Und Effie Priest, also einfach alles drei gemeinsam. Erstmal den Casinobrand, den berühmten Lausanne Casinobrand. Weil er eigentlich Casino spielen wollte, aber dann nicht konnte und deswegen ein Buch geschrieben hat? Ich frage mich, wer hat am meisten davon, ein Casinobrand zu sehen? Ja, ja, sehr gut. Leute, die sehr viel verloren haben. Cui Bono. Hm? Cui Bono. Hm? Wem geht's gut? Es klingt so tot, ich habe so einen Fäulegeruch in der Nase, als würde gerade eine tote Sprache gesprochen werden. Wem geht's gut deswegen? Wem ging es denn deswegen gut? Wem geht's weswegen gut? Genau, gute Frage. Ich glaube, es ist jemand, der vielleicht Wettschulden hat, Extremwettschulden bei diesem Casino. Ja. Jemand, der weiss, dass die Geräte manipuliert wurden?
Nee, der hat ja kein Interesse, dass es auffliegt. Oder jemand, der, vielleicht der Besitzer, der die manipuliert hat, der Investigativjournalist, der seit ... Der sie falsch herum manipuliert hat, dass die Leute nie gewinnen können. Genau, richtig. Das finde ich gut. Ich setze alles auf die fünf. Rianne Verplü, die neun. Moment mal, das Brett hat gar keine fünf.
Ah, okay.
Ich hätte gar nicht gewinnen können.
Und im Hintergrund so, was machen Sie da? Und der Besitzer steht so mit so einer Servierte.
Und hat so eine fünf in der Hand.
Und es heisst, der Film heisst Ocean's Five. Nee, Smoke on the Water. Kann das ja auch ein Untertitel sein. Ja. Ocean's Five, Smoke on the Water. We just, we only have enough money for five actors. Oder Achtung, Take Five. Oh, oh, oh, oh. Take Five und er klaut die Fünf. Oder, wie wär's, also erstmal rein rechtlich, ich sage, gut, hier, zwei Millionen auf die dreiundzwanzig, sie haben keine zwei Millionen, ja, ich mache hier die Regeln, nein, wir machen hier die Regeln, wir sind das Casino, fünf Millionen auf die dreiundzwanzig, dann er sagt, ich werf's rein kurz, wie die das sagen, dreht's rum, und dann steck ich aber das Casino in Brand. Ja, was mein Mandant hier meinte mit diesem Ich-mach-hier-die-Regeln. Können Sie noch mal ganz kurz erklären, was Sie da... Warum haben Sie gesagt, ich mach hier die Regeln? Das ist vor Gericht ein ganz schlechter Satz. Hören Sie, ich mach hier die Regeln, ich sag sage, wo es lang geht. Okay, gut. Hat er in so einem Wie-How-to-become-in-Alpha-Buch oder so gelesen. Sagen Sie immer, ich mache hier die Regeln. Okay. I'm the man. Und so. Ja, I'm the oldest boy. I'm the oldest boy. Nee, aber ich denke, du nimmst zwei Millionen Euro auf die 23. Die du nicht hast. Ist jetzt egal. So egal, weiß ich nicht. Für die Einfachheit der Story habe ich zwei Millionen Euro. Franken, wir sind in der Schweiz noch. Also, Franken, ich lege die auf die 23. Jetzt fängt das an zu drehen. Ich stecke währenddessen den Casinotisch in Brand. So. Meine zwei Millionen Euro sind weg, verbrannt. Aber vielleicht habe ich ja sogar gewonnen. Das heißt, ich habe zu gleichen, das ist ja Schrödingers Roulette-Tisch. Ich habe zu gleichen Teilen zwei Millionen Euro verloren. Also du zündest dein eigenes Geld an, um während alles an... Nein, Geld, den Tisch, das Casino. Okay. Jemand anderes macht, steckt das Casino. Noch bevor das Ergebnis der Kugel feststeht. In der Zwischenzeit zwischen, ich habe wasetzt, hin zu das Ergebnis ist da, ist das Casino abgebrannt, okay? Ich habe zu gleichen Teilen, null Euro, zwei Millionen Euro und jetzt alle wahrscheinlich... Und 36 mal zwei Millionen Euro. Ja, oder halt, wenn ich, genau, also vielleicht aber auch, ja... Wenn du gewonnen hättest. Stimmt.
Genau.
Ja, der Teil, der mich noch irritiert,
Herr Tietze an dem Teil, warum haben Sie denn das Casino in Brand gesetzt?
Weiß ich nicht.
Es war jemand anderes.
Plötzlich war es in Brand.
Ja, schwierig, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Ich weiß auch nicht genau, wie das aussieht, wie man das setzt.
Sind das nicht so Chips genau aus dem Grund, dass die nicht verbrennen können, weil das der gängige Trick war von Betrügern einfach ihr eigenes Geld zu verbrennen? Und daher kommen Jetons. Deswegen sind Jetons so, wie sie sagen. Jetons. Ja, okay, kann sein, kann wirklich sein. Sind die deswegen, sind es Chips? Nee. Okay, ich glaube, meine grösste Angst wäre, vor Gericht zu sein. Und dann werde ich aber so ganz unvorteilhaft gezeichnet von diesem Gerichtszeichner. Weil anscheinend darfst du ja in Gerichtsseilen keine Fotos machen, deswegen gibt's die Zeichner. Und die haben ja eine enorme Macht, weil die können ja den Angeklagten schon mal direkt mit zu hörnen und so mit zu stink... So eine Summe, die so durchgekattet ist. So darstellen und du kannst nichts dagegen sagen, weil das ja das einzige Beweismaterial ist aus dem Gerichtssaal, das es gibt. Und ich würde einfach die ganze Zeit immer nur zu diesem Gerichtszeichner gucken und immer so versuchen, möglichst zu posieren. Aber es ist auch ein dummer Job, weil es ist, glaube ich, es gibt einfach, hat schon mal jemand und der Richter so, können Sie zu mir gucken? Ja. Ja, wenn die Schokoladenseite dem zeigen. Hat schon mal jemand den Gerichtszeichner verklagt, weil er das Bild so unvorteilhaft fand und dann war er wieder vor Gericht und dann hatte der Gerichtszeichner aber gar keinen Bock auf den und malte ihn so richtig unvorteilhaft. Weil der Gerichtszeichner in seinem eigenen Prozess derjenige ist. Ist das gegen die Regeln? Er zeichnet mich jetzt gerade, er zeichnet mich jetzt gerade, was ist das? Ich habe keinen Hut auf. Er darf zeichnen, er darf zeichnen, was er will. Stopp, stopp. Er kann zeichnen, was er will, er kann zeichnen. Das kann nicht wahr sein. Machen Sie eine Gegenzeichnung. Okay. Finde ich nicht so schlecht. Aber es ist auch komisch, es ist ein Beruf, der einfach von einer Sekunde auf den nächsten verschwindet, wenn man sagt, ja nee, lass uns einfach Fotos machen. Ja klar, also was für eine dumme Regel. Ich habe mich damit verschrieben. Also das ist ja, also ich meine, klar, viele Jobs können ersetzt werden durch Technik und so, aber ich glaube, es gibt immer so eine gewisse Übergangszeit. Moment, weil Gerichtszeichner nur gut darin sind, Gericht von innen zu zeichnen. Ja, natürlich. Ich als Gerichtszeichner würde jeden Tag im Bett liegen und aufmachen und sagen, wo ist mein Handy? Und? Oh, okay, es wurde noch nicht erlaubt. Schatz, was ist los? Es wurde noch nicht erlaubt, dass Fotos gemacht werden im Gerichtszeit. Oh Gott, wieder diese Scheiße. Wieder du mit deiner Scheiße. Es kann sein, dass du mich aber auch nicht so wirklich unterstützt in meinem Beruf. Dein Bild von Beziehungen ist auch immer so ein bisschen arg einseitig, habe ich manchmal das Gefühl, Stefan, müssen wir da mal drüber reden. Oh, zum Glück habe ich meinen Job nicht verloren. Oh, du wieder mit deiner Scheiße, ey! Das ist viel zu hart. Schatz, ich versuche, uns ins Essen auf den Tisch zu bekommen. Du mit deiner... Unnötig aggressiv. Nee, es liegt nicht an meinem Bild von Beziehungen. Nein, nein, es ist gut. Da ist alles in Ordnung, alles gut. Alles gut. Oh, es ist so geil gerade alles, ey. Warst du nicht letztens in dieser Talkshow? Nein. Weil es war zwar eine Schattenwand, aber ich glaube, ich habe dich erkannt, weil du ja doch ein sehr markantes... Weil ich meinen Stefan-Hut aufhatte, wo mein Name draufsteht. Ich dachte, man erkennt das nicht, aber die Schattenwand wurde hinten einfach gross Stefan. Ja, weil es war so eine Krawall-Talkshow mit dem Namen Nein, Frauen sind Schweine, wo du sehr prominent gesprochen hast. Aber ist das eigentlich jemals passiert in diesen hunderten Jahren der Krawall-Talkshow, dass jemand hinter einer Schattenwand sitzt und die andere Person sagt, ach, Karl, hm?
Und die Schattenwand so ...
Nein.
Ach so, nee, ist offensichtlich ein Hase, ein Häschen.
Ist offensichtlich ein wunderschönes Häschen.
Ich dachte, er ist Karl, mein Nachbar, der offensichtlich mich stalkt.
Offensichtlich meinen Ex-Freund Karl, den ich vor dem Studio gesehen habe. Da habe ich sein Auto gesehen. Glaubst du, wenn man damals gemalt wurde von Porträtisten, da ging oft mal was zurück? Also glaubst du, angenommen, keine Ahnung, Wagner wurde ja von Rembrandt gezeichnet. Insane! Und dann engagierst du Rembrandt, der dich malt. Herr Rembrandt, geil, vielen Dank, dass ich das mache. Ich hätte nicht gesagt, dass Sie jemals auf meine Mail antworten. Also jetzt kommen Sie umsonst vorbei aus Geil. In 19 Tagen sind Sie angereist aus fucking Bern, Holland, wo auch immer. Kein Problem. Natürlich für Sie, Herr Wagner, das ist doch klar. Gut, vielen Dank. Können Sie mich ... Okay, soll ich mich so hinsetzen? Mit dem Hut? Ja, ich dachte, der Hut. Ich kann auch einen Hut nehmen. Ah, das ist ... einzigartig auf jeden Fall. Okay, es klingt negativ. Also, ne ... aber ... es wird für unser Jahrhundert eher ... Eher ... also ... Unpassend. Eher unpassend? Ich biete mal was an. Und ich habe die Augen zu. Ich habe rote Augen. Naja, Sie waren ja ein bisschen nervös und ein bisschen verschwitzt. Ich dachte, Sie können doch entscheiden, wie es aussieht. Naja, aber es geht natürlich auch um Naturalismus. Ich muss Sie natürlich für die Nachwelt genauso einfangen, wie sie sind. Das ist ja hier Porträtkunst und nicht ein Wunschkonzert. Hab ich dann, wir versessen uns das alle mal an Richard Wagner hinein. Haben wir jetzt alle, haben wir drei Note-Rounds? Ich glaube, es gibt ein bisschen was, was man machen kann, ja. Weil beim Fotografen kriegst du dann ja auch Fotos geschickt. Und dann kannst du die Nummer 2115. Dann kriegst du die halt 19 Abzüge davon. Ich liebe die Zahlen 19. Ich habe schon sehr oft benutzt diesen Podcast. Kann ich vielleicht eine Brille aufhaben oder so, weil das jetzt ein bisschen von den Augen her. Oder kann ich vielleicht nicht so ein ganz schmales, ganz schmales Gesicht haben. Oder ganz starke, coole Wangenkknochen und wie so eine geile Jawline haben. Ja. Oder wenn dann so irgendwie
plötzlich dann so eine neue Mode,
so eine neue Kunstrichtung kommt,
so Kubismus oder sowas,
und dann so der erste Graf,
der mit dem neuen Stil gemalt wurde,
der dann so drei Rechtecke
und zwei Kreise hat und dann so
okay.
Ich finde das ja klasse mit dem neuen Stil und das ist ja modern. Das machen jetzt alle so. Ja, genau. Erst mal, vielen Dank, dass sie sich für Juan Gris entschieden haben. Ja, sie haben ja letzte Woche meinen Onkel gemalt. Sie, sie, sie. Also perfekt, wie als stünde er vor mir. Genau. Und jetzt in der letzten Woche hat sich ... Kubismus hat gesagt, Kubismus hat gesagt, so hier ist jetzt ich bin da und alle malen so und nee, ist voll die coole Kunstrichtung. Es wird immer abstrakter. Voll cool, voll cool. Es wird immer mehr Form, geometrische Form und sowas, weniger Farben, alles ein bisschen zurückgenommen, entsetzt. Super, aber jetzt für ein Porträt, weil ich meine, das ist ja ich habe ja jetzt die drei Rechtecke und zwei Kreise. Nee, genau. Das macht dann 13.000 Gulden. Oh, Gulden, ja. Ne, also ist schon ... Ich muss auch weiter, weil ich habe nur ein paar Porträttermine heute. Alles klar, gut. Und diese Kunstform hielt sich genau für eine Woche. Genau. Und ab nächster Woche malten alle wieder ganz normaleräte. Und bis dahin nur dieser eine Graf, dieser eine Graf zwanghaft, dieser eine Graf von Zwang Zollern einfach hat dieses kubistische Bild. Aber auch so verschoben. Wie wird denn, also Gulden, ich meine, damals gab Gulden und gut ist. Wenn jetzt so der Graf von Zwang anhalt, gulden gab es nur in Holland. Ja, meinst du? Aber ist gulden nicht einfach
golden? Ja, okay.
Wenn die heute in unsere Welt kommen,
mal so eine witzige Komödie.
Der Graf von Starbucks
Nanunana.
Das ist jetzt der Arbeitstitel.
So, im Sinne von
Graf aus alter Zeit ist neu.
Und dann fragt ihr so,
okay, ich habe jetzt hier 16 Gulden dabei, was ist eure Währung? Ethereum.
Also, ist das ein neuer Name für Gulden?
Nee, es ist eine Kryptowährung.
Ist Krypto ein neuer Name für Gold?
Ja, von denen gibt es Hunderte verschiedene, Tausende verschiedene. Jeder kann quasi seine eigene Währung machen. Könntest du mir kurz den Stroheim da geben? Ja genau, das sind 14 Euro. Kannst du mir kurz irgendwas … Also du kannst auch mit Rossmann Punkten zahlen, von Rossmann Rossmann-Drogerie. Rossmann-Drogerie?
Ja. Rossmann, ein Mann auf dem Ross? Nee, mit Shampoo und so. Shampoo? Also mit denen, wo man die Haare sauber macht. Der neue Sat.1-Film-Film. Guck die, guck die. Der Graf von Starbucks Nanunana. Der Graf von Starbucks Nanunana. Guck die an. Guck die jetzt an. Guck die nächste Woche an. die werden, man denkt immer, die werden so ultra geflasht von unserer modernen Welt. Ich glaube, die werden eher enttäuscht. Wenn wer sagt so, ja, also wir haben jetzt so Lasertechnologie entwickelt, damit können wir auf Feinde schießen, auf Feinde schießen, uns entharnen, die Haare wegmachen. Wieso denn entharnen? Naja, damit man halt, also wir haben auch mal ein Messer, aber du kannst, also wir bündeln Licht, extrem komprimiertes Licht und damit machen wir dann die Haare weg. Köpft Feinde, köpft Feinden die Köpfe weg? Dafür ist es nicht stark genug. Du kannst nur die Haare und dann dauert es ein bisschen länger, bis sie wieder nachwachsen.
Und dann wird man eigentlich als moderner Mensch von diesem alten Urahm gedisst die ganze Zeit.
Die ganze Zeit nur so, oh, Pussy.
Hm, was hast du gesagt?
Hm, nee, nichts.
Nee, aber willst du mal entharren, weil es ist...
Nein, ich will nicht fucking entharren.
Ich dachte, die Zukunft wäre cool, okay?
Ja, wir haben schon auch wirklich viele coole Sachen.
Ja, jetzt kommt der mit Ethereum. Ja, weil das ist dezentral. Und es ist halt ziemlich heiß jetzt auch. Wir haben so ziemlich alles verbrannt. Und tötet sich einfach. Aber er hält es nicht aus. Aber er hat ein Schwert, ne? Er hat dann am Ende so noch ein Schwert. Also säßen wir wirklich jetzt einfach mit Schwertern hier
so völlig normal,
einfach extrem nervig für Ton,
klimpert die ganze Zeit rum,
und du brauchst es ja quasi nie.
Hat man mit dem Schwert auch so
sich ein Stück Käse abgeschnitten?
Kann gut sein, oder mal so als Rückenkratzer,
ich meine, wenn du so ein Ding hast,
dann fallen dir auch Dinge ein, die du machst. Also dann so Rückenkratzen oder mal so halt irgendwie oben vom Regal im Supermarkt, wenn dann mal die Kellogs von oben und einfach so sching und der ganze Supermarkt auch sching und er so, nee, nee, ich wollte nur oben. Ah ja, ach so. Ah ja. Schum, schum. Wir hatten gedacht, dass wir das mal benutzen, aber nee.
Du bist doch ein großer Mittelalter-Fan.
Lieb ich. Hast du mal in den Mittelalter-Waffen geschwungen? Hast du mal einen richtigen Zweihänder geschwungen? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Wie schwer sind die? Lächerlich schwer? Ich besitze einen. Ich habe so einen kugelförmigen Lampenschirm bei mir in der Wohnung. Kugelförmigen Lampenschirm. Und der ist, sage ich mal, durchaus malträtiert worden. Den hat es ab und zu in Mitleidenschaft gezogen. Das sind Zweihänder und Einhänder. Das sind anderthalb Händer. Doch, ich bin jetzt nicht mehr interessiert. Kann man entweder mit einem oder mit zwei Händen führen. Und ja, damit habe ich eine Zeit lang trainiert, weil ich mir dachte, wenn es hart auf hart kommt, ist es auch schon ein Fünf- oder ein Dreitürer?
Das ist, glaub ich, die gleiche Frage.
Es sind viereinhalb Türen.
Das heutige ... Ist es ein Dreie- oder Fünftürer?
Das damalige ist ein Ein- oder Zweihänder.
Ja.
Was trägst du für ein Schwert?
Ist es ein Rapier oder ein Degen?
Rapier. Anderthalbhänder, 1,2 Finger.
Ein anderthalbgängiger Rapier mit Fingerring. Sohn, du bist eine Enttäuschung. Aber das ist ein Familienerbstück, das kommt von Opa? Ja, Opa war auch eine Enttäuschung. Als ob ich mir ein Schwert leisten könnte. Einzige, was ich besitze, ist ein Esel. Verkauf den Esel oder den Schwert, den Zweihänder, vernünftigen Zweihänder.
Mit Unterbodenbeleuchtung, Bassbox.
Okay.
Ich hab's mir ein Auto verkauft.
Oh, Stefan24.de!
Hup, hup!
Geht niemals auf Stefan24.de, okay?
Das war jetzt ein Scherz, können wir das rausschneiden?
Ja.
Es war ...
Es war keine ... Auf diese Phase war ich nicht stolz. Ich hab alle Dienste angeboten, ich hab nicht klar eine Grenze gezogen. Weil als Stefan gehört hat, dass jeder eine Währung machen kann, hat er die Stefan-Dollar gemacht und hat eine Plattform gemacht, wo man alles kaufen kann, nur mit Stefan-Dollar. Das war Stefan24. Hör auf, das wird wiederholen. Ich möchte es einfach nur sagen. Er wiederholt es halt nicht. Es hat auch ein Loch in unsere Finanzen gerissen, weil du halt einen Grossteil unserer Einnahmen hast in Stefan Dollar umgewandelt und ich habe dich gefragt, okay, was ist denn der Wechselkurs und dann hast du gesagt, na Stefan Dollar sind sehr wertvoll, 100 Euro sind ein Stefan Dollar und am Ende hatten wir irgendwie sieben Stefan Dollar und damit konnten wir nicht mal auf Stefan24 was kaufen. Also, wie soll ich das meinem aus der Zeit hergereisten Onkel dem Graf von Starbucks und Nanunana erklären, der unser Wirtschaftssystem eh noch Schwierigkeiten hat? Stefan. Das ist der zweite Trailer. Sat1-Filmfilm, nächste Woche hier auf Sat1, schaut rein, schaut rein. Das war jetzt der zweite Trailer. Ich liebe unseren Film. Immer noch Take Five, oder ist das ein anderer Film? Nee, nee, der Graf Mahlsang. Ach so, der Graf Mahlsang von, ja, der sagt dann so, wer ist dieser, ich sehe überall das Wappen von Starbucks, das muss ja einer der, also der versteht die Welt nicht, ähm, der muss ja, der muss ja einer der mächtigsten Fürsten eurer Zeit sein, wo ist seine Burg? Und dann sagt man so, ja, da direkt neben Five Guys. Five Guys! Oh, bringen wir alle fünf Herren! Oh, ein Söldner her! Da muss ich mir auch... Und dann halt solche Sachen... Mein Gott, du schenkst doch! Mein Gott, du kriegst doch hin! Mein Gott, es ist ein Trailer, es ist jetzt auch nicht so schwer! Schreibt's euch doch einfach selber mal das Drehbuch, schreibt's doch von alleine! Mann, ey, das ist doch jetzt wirklich, ich muss dir nicht alles erklären. Mein Gott, ich muss doch nicht die ganzen Filme euch vortanzen. Das ist jetzt eine nette Idee, aber es ist noch ... Sollen wir es euch auch noch finanzieren? Boah, jetzt wird es doch selber hin. Meine Fresse, ey. Ab 24. auf Netflix. Ich finde, Trailer sind irgendwie auch komisch. Das ist aktiv geworden. Ich habe mein Auto jetzt verkauft, es ist weg, tschüss. Hast du Kontakt mit dem Käufer, also dass man da in der Woche so, geht es ihr gut? Ich habe es in so einer Firma verkauft. Dann geht man da online, gibt man alle seine Daten ein, drei, fünf, Thürer, Farbe, blablabla, und dann kriegt man einen Preis gesagt, und wenn man damit zufrieden ist, fährt man dann da hin, dann gucken die sich auch nochmal an, und alle waren sehr unsympathisch da, alle sehr unsympathisch, mochte ich gar nicht, mochte die ganze Welt nicht.
Es war ein komischer kleiner Hinterhof, die haben dann angefangen zu rauchen in der Werkstatt und sowas.
Alles war ein bisschen weird.
Die Autos oder die?
Die Menschen haben geraucht in der Werkstatt.
Ja.
Dieses.
Sieht man manchmal noch.
So wie wir uns Rauchen vorstellen. Genau. Und dann haben die mir einen Preis gemacht. Ich habe gesagt, hier will ich mein Auto nicht stehen lassen. Weil es war mein allererstes Auto, habe ich immer noch gehabt. Was du darin alles erlebt hast. Ich habe wirklich viele erste und letzte Male darin erlebt und dachte mir, wow, ist so toll, dieses Auto. Und dann war ich ein bisschen emotional, dann war ich da, habe mich gar nicht wohlgefühlt an diesem Ort, habe niemanden gemocht, weil ich fand das alles ganz schlimm. Und dann haben die mir einen Preis gesagt, der gut war und ich habe sofort eingeschlagen. Ich Ich habe sofort ... Ja, Deal, Deal, Deal, Deal, Deal. Und dann habe ich mich noch mal ins Auto gesetzt, kurz. Warum auch immer, also gelernt, so Abschied nehmen von etwas, noch mal reingesetzt. Gibt man dir da so, wir geben Ihnen jetzt noch einen Moment mit? Die waren nicht so, ich war so. Ich habe mir das alles so vorgestellt. Okay, dann würden wir das Auto direkt mitnehmen. Okay, kommt dann weiter. Kann ich mich noch mal kurz reinsetzen? Was? Entschuldigung, machen Sie doch den Motor aus. Ob ich mich noch kurz noch mal reinsetzen kann. Ach mein Gott, ja, wenn es unbedingt sein muss. Ich habe mein erstes Auto. Lappenkasper. Lappenkasper. Komm, setz dich hein. Okay. Und da war auch so ein Typ dann so, ja, hier kommen Reihen zur Unterschrift. Und ich so, ja, okay. Und es war sehr kalt die Stimmung und ich hab gesagt, das war mein erstes Auto, das schreibt man schon ein bisschen emotional. Und er hat dann literally gesagt, ja, hast ja wahrscheinlich eh bald ein Neues. Hast ja wahrscheinlich eh bald ein neues, so als wäre er aber auch sauer, wie ich es meinem Auto anschauen, als hätte ich so gerade Schluss gemacht und er sagt, ja, ist ja bald eh wieder eine neue, so also so, ja, ja, ja, wahrscheinlich schon. Aber er klingt für mich auch nicht richtig ausgeglichen. Also hat er auch gerade irgendwie ein Problem oder so? Also findet er gerade kein Auto? Ist das letzte Auto von ihm schon eine Weile her?
Hat sein Auto ihn mit einem anderen Besitzer? Er klingt für mich auch nicht richtig ausgeglichen. Also hat er auch gerade irgendwie ein Problem oder so? Also findet er gerade kein Auto? Ist das letzte Auto von ihm schon eine Weile her?
Hat sein Auto ihn mit einem anderen Besitzer betrogen?
Ja, also ich finde, da spürt man auch ein bisschen Schwingungen, dass er vielleicht selber gerade nicht in der besten Auto bezieht.
Ja, ist er wahrscheinlich eh bald ein neues.
So ein Typ wie du findet ja eh sofort ein neues Auto.
Danke.
Ein Typ wie du hat wahrscheinlich neun Autos. Ja, und Leute wie ich müssen Fahrrad fahren. So, jetzt unterschreib hier. Ja, okay, sie können sich ja mit dem Geld auch ein Auto kaufen, ist ja kein Problem. Ja, wenn's so leicht wär. Es ist literally so leicht, man geht einfach in ... Ja, okay, alles klar, warum hab ich dann seit drei Jahren kein Auto? Ich we nicht. Ich schreib hier, okay? Ja, sorry. Kann ich mich noch mal kurz reinsetzen?
Ekelhaft.
Das ist ja rumknutschen im Auto dann.
Das verstört andere Leute, okay?
Nicht jeder ist so glücklich mit seinem Auto.
Und ja, genau da habe ich es dann stehen lassen. Wie musst du dir das vorstellen?
Du sitzt im Auto und dann so dieser klassische Lenkrad.
Ja, das habe ich dann erst nicht gemacht, weil die auch geguckt haben. Die standen in so einer Werkstatt. Guck mal, jetzt fasst er das Lenkrad an, ey, Jesus Christ. Ich wickst er auf sein Lenkrad, ich will das nicht ... Also ich fasse das nicht mehr an. Gott, weint er? Ach Gott, was macht er denn jetzt? Gott, wie er den Schaltknüppel anfasst. Oh mein Gott, ey, setz dich doch auf den Schaltknüppel. Jesus Christ, sorry. Ich weiß nicht, wo das jetzt herkam, aber die waren so wenig wie vorgestellt, dass sie solche harten, doofen Sprüche machen. Ja. Naja, und dann fand ich es auch lächerlich, dass ich die Mitarre eingesetzt habe. Überhaupt nicht, das ist überhaupt nicht lächerlich. Das ist total menschlich, und ich find's super, dass du so emotional bist.
Und dass du da auch ...
Aber ist es Emotionalität oder ist es nicht gelernt?
Es ist nicht einfach aus dem Film gelernt. Ich war schon emotional.
Ist es ja auch in Ordnung?
Du kannst ja auch mit Filmritualen echte Emotionen abarbeiten.
Faken.
Es ist ja nicht nur, weil das Ritual fake ist,
muss ja die dahinterliegende Emotion nicht falsch sein,
sondern du kannst ja auch wirklich dann mal so ein ...
So was ... So einen Moment geben, so den Zirrettenanzünder. Und dann so, fuck! Fuck! Das hat aber jeder schon mal geträumt, oder? So Zirrettenanzünder als Lippenstift? Das war doch schon mal die Fantasie von jedem. Ah, finde ich nicht schlecht. Oder, dass man so ... Während er an ist? Ja, dass halt so verschiedene Farben ... Danach hast du aber rote Lippen, das kann ich dir aber sagen. Das will ich aber noch sagen. Sag's. Dann hat man aber rote Lippen. Dass man dann aber rote Lippen hätte. Ich bin noch die ganze Woche hier. Shows. Du bist emotional, ich habe das Gefühl, du hast noch nicht wirklich abgeschlossen. Oder hast du mittlerweile schon direkt Neues? Doch, relativ schnell. Ja, Stefan hat natürlich am nächsten Tag wieder Neues. War das der Grund, warum du dein Altes verkauft hast, weil du schon Neues hast? Ne, es war Trennung und dann gucken. Wie viel Zeit muss man sich nehmen, nach einem Auto verkaufen? Es ist völlig okay, wenn ihr dann sofort Neues habt. Ich find's nur uncool, wenn es sich überschneidet. Das find ich richtig uncool. Weil das solltet ihr niemandem antun. Und du bist jetzt auf der Suche grade, oder wie ... Nee, grade erst mal happy, wie alles ... Ich bin erst mal happy, wie es ist. Aber genau, offen für Neues. Also auch für andere Dinge mal auszuprobieren, also vielleicht auch gar kein Auto, sondern vielleicht mal wirklich was ganz anderes ausprobieren. Ein Motorrad? Ja, warum nicht, ey, weißt du, man entscheidet sich sehr früh für etwas oder auch nicht oder man denkt, man will etwas, vielleicht will jemand aber eine andere Sache oder vielleicht will man beides. Einfach mal ausprobieren. Ja, einfach mal ausprobieren. Du weißt ja nicht, wovon du redest, wenn du es nicht ausprobierst. Nee, eben. Hast du schon mal andere Sachen ausprobiert? Oder so ein Liegerad oder so. Hast du schon mal andere Sachen ausprobiert oder bist du nur immer eine Sache gefahren? Ja, meine Oma hatte mal so ein Fahrrad mit drei Rädern. Bist du das mal gefahren? Das bin ich mal gefahren. Du musst Dinge ausprobieren. Es ist einfach schwierig, weil du kannst dich nicht so richtig in die Kurve legen, weil es hat ja drei Räder, weswegen du ... Nur geradeaus fahren kannst. Das heißt, du musst deine Reise extrem penibel planen, du musst schon am Anfang der Reise dein Fahrrad genau richtig ausrichten, um genau in die Nähe zu kommen und dann musst du absteigen und dann zum Marktplatz laufen und dann wieder zurück. Oder du lässt dich einfach treiben, das find ich auch gut. Dass du einfach sagst, geradeaus. Ich guck, ich bin, ja, ich guck, wo ich lande. Und da bin ich dann, den Rest des Tages. Dann geh ich abends zurück. Aber ich liebe es, bin ich mit so einer Yes-And-Ein, das mein neues Wochenende-Hobby, ist, mit Freunden und Drinks durch die Stadt zu laufen und gucken, was sich ergibt. Yes- and zu sagen, zu allem, was sich ergibt, alle Sidequests anzunehmen, und es macht sehr viel Spaß. Was für verrückte, unglaublich interessante Dinge habt ihr da so erlebt? Naja, man sitzt einfach rum, trinkt und dann geht man abends nach Hause. Okay, also so crazy Sachen, wo man dann sagt, boah, da erinnere ich mich in zehn Jahren noch dran. Nee, also eigentlich, man redet über die gleichen zehn Anekdoten, die man früher zusammen erlebt hat. Krass. Und dann geht man abends allein nach Hause und weint sich nicht in den Schlaf. Okay, und dann kommt plötzlich jemand so und meint so, ey, ich suche noch so nach drei jungen Leuten, ich habe hier einen kleinen Auftrag, habt ihr Bock mitzumachen? Ist nicht ganz legal, aber ich sage mal so, es lohnt sich. Und dann würden wir sagen, nee, es ist jetzt schon spät. Okay. Nee, es passiert leider auch nicht so. Ich bin irgendwie aus der Vergangenheit hierher geraten. Könnt ihr mir so ein bisschen ... Graf Starbucks und Nanunana? Ja, ja, Mann. Ich habe mich schnell eingelegt, Digga. Sat.1, Film, Film. Sat.1, Film, Film. Das ist es doch. Das wollt ihr doch alle sehen. Setz euch, pflanzt euch vor den Fernseher und guckt den Film. Hättet ihr Geschmack, würdet ihr diesen Sender gar nicht sehen jetzt gerade, okay? Machen wir uns doch nichts vor. Mein Gott, Leute, ey. Wir sind alle hier, wir machen uns doch was vor. Glatzt mich nicht so an, schau mich nicht an hier. Schau mich nicht an, deine bohrenden Blicke. Gott, ey, weiss doch, was ihr Bock darauf habt. Also, schaut da eins Filmfilmen. So, jetzt habe ich mein Auto stehen lassen, bin nicht emotional gewesen, dann so richtig mehr, dachte mir, ja, im Endeffekt ist es einfach auch nur ein Auto und das ist alles gerade meine Emotion und ich muss auf mich hören, bla bla bla. Ich habe stehen gelassen, losgegangen, mich in den erstbesten Miles, Car to go, whatever gesetzt und bin nach Hause gefahren, lauten Musik an, dachte mir, tja. Also du hast sie direkt käuflich nächstbeste Gelegenheit genommen. Nächstbeste von der Strasse genommen, ja.
Nicht mal im Bus gefahren? Du im Bus, das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Doch, bin ich so früher, bin ich zur Schule immer im Bus gefahren.
Ich kann mir dich nicht im Bus vorstellen.
Immer im Bus gefahren.
Wirklich so richtig, dass man so hin und her geschleudert wird und du wie so eine Gitarrenseite.
Ich kann mir dich nicht so vorstellen. Ich kann mir dich nicht vorstellen, wie du um dein Gleichgewicht ringst. Ah, das finde ich nicht schlecht. Das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen. Das finde ich nicht schlecht. Du bist für mich so ein stabiler, statischer Fels, so eine Säule in der Brandung, so eine Salzstatue, so ein unbewegliches, festes, starres Ding. Und ich kann mir dich gar nicht so... Wabbelig vorstellen. So gar nicht. So du in dem Erdbeben? Ich müsste wegschauen, glaube ich. Ich würde brechen. Ich würde in der Mitte durchbrechen. Es gibt Menschen, die sind gebaut für Erdbeben, es sind Menschen, die sind dafür nicht gemacht. Du bist wie so ein Teller. Du bist wie so ein Teller. Ich habe letzte Woche zwei Teller zerdeppert. Du bist aber ein Deppermann auch. Ich habe zwei Teller zerdeppert und zwar einmal war ich einfach bei der, ich wollte es abwischen mit dem Schwamm und dann war da aber so ein hartnäckiger Fleck, Barbecue-Sauce, trocken, ich glaube das kennt man. I know exactly. Und dann habe ich da so fest und dann war ich so fest gedrückt, dass ich mir selber den Teller aus der Hand gedrückt habe und in die Spüle reingeschleudert habe. Aber du hast ihn hast ihn nicht kaputt gemacht, sondern erst dann... Ne, genau, er ist, ich habe, also, ich war selbst stärker als ich selbst. Ich habe zu viel Kraft aufgewendet, dass ich selber es nicht mehr festhalten konnte. Ne, ne, eine rechte Hand war stärker als eine linke, was sehr üblich ist für Rechtshänder. Ja, das kann sein. Für goofy Menschen, wie ich sage. Und es ist eigentlich eine extrem gefährliche Disbalance, dass der Mensch diese unterschiedlichen Kräfte in sich vereint. Hey, alles gut. Nee, das kriegst du hin. Das ist doch Quatsch, dass ein Arm stärker ist als der andere. Das ist eine schwache Seite und eine starke Seite. Und es kämpft die ganze Zeit miteinander. Aber einer ist immer unterlegen. Es ist immer einer unterlegen. Ich hatte natürlich einen TikTok gesehen, das hat mich für alle Zeiten verändert. Das hat mir nämlich gesagt, das war irgendwie so ein Test, welche Gehirnhälfte von dir
ist die bestimmende? Und das war, dann guckt man oben, guckt man sich was an, man kann zwei Dinge erkennen. Glaubst du Scheiße, die du auf TikTok hörst, dann ist die linke Seite die bestimmende. Wenn nicht, dann ist die rechte Seite die bestimmende. Und ich dachte immer, ich wäre ein Logiker, aber ich bin eher die intuitive Seite. Ich bin die intuitiv-emotionale Seite.
Das hätte ich auch sein können.
Ich dachte immer, ich wäre die logische, von Ratio bestimmte Seite.
Stell dir vor, nein, nein, nein.
Und wie hat das TikTok das getestet?
Weiß nicht, ob ich bei diesem Minecraft-Bild eher,
weiß nicht, die Frau sehe oder den Gral.
Du bist kein Gral-Ritter, oder was?
Du bist kein Auserwählter von Artus.
Das ist der Beste. Graal.
Du bist kein Graalsritter, oder was? Du bist kein Auserwählter von Artus. Du bist nicht Teil der Tafelrunde. Ich war, ich bin nicht eingeladen. Ich bin schon wieder nicht eingeladen zur Tafelrunde. Scheiße. Ich frag dich jetzt, als jemand, der schon ein paar Mal da war, zu oft, aber wollte ich mal fragen, wie kommt man jetzt, also was muss ich tun, um noch Teil der Tafelrundende zu werden? Naja, es ist natürlich schwer, weil die Tafelrunde ist ja ein Kreis, das heißt, Runde, ich verstehe schon, ich verstehe wie Geometrie works. Okay, ja, gut, weil wenn du dann sagst, lass uns doch einen neuen Stuhl hinzustellen, geht nicht so leicht, weil du musst ja den Radius quasi erhöhen, das heißt, du kannst ja einen Kreis nicht einfach größer machen, bei einem rechteckigen Tisch stellst du einfach noch einen rechteckigen Tisch dazu. Das kannst du unendlich oft machen. Bei einem Kreis super schwer. Wenn jetzt da irgendwie Lord Stephan da dazukommt, kannst du ja sagen, rück mal ein Stück, und dann muss das wie so eine Laoda-Welle durch den ganzen Kreis gehen. Ja, nee, nee. Ich bringe meinen eigenen Stuhl mit und würde mich einfach so daneben setzen. Na, das geht nicht. Du kannst nicht Teil der Tafel wie, einfach alleine, ohne Tisch? Ja, genau. Oder ich bringe mir so einen eigenen Tisch mit, so einen Klapptisch mitbringen. Der muss aber auch rund sein. Du bist dann wie so ein Planet. Ja, genau. Ich kann auch mich ... Ich kann auch langsam rumgehen um den Tisch. Okay. Mit meinem kleinen Tisch. Es geht nicht, leider. Wenn du nicht irgendeine geometrische Methode findest, wie man einen Kreis vergrössern kann. Donut. Ein grosser Donut-shaped Tisch. Weiter. Pass auf, ich gehe zu meinem Kumpel, der ist Schreiner, Tischler. Ja, Jesus. Ja, das ist aber jetzt egal, gehört jetzt hier nicht hin. Okay, ich habe ihn, habe euch letztens zusammen gesehen und ich habe mich gefragt, aber gut. So, und jetzt baue ich einen grossen Donut-shaped Tisch. Weiter. Und die Aussparung ist genauso gross wie der Tisch, den Artus gerade hat. Und ich lege den Tisch auf den Tisch von Artus. Und schon haben wir mehr Platz für mehr Leute am Tisch. Sching! Oh. Damit schlage ich dich. Nein! Ich dachte, du willst mich umbringen. Passiert auf, das Ritter dann selber. Ja, genau. Bereit sind. Nein, ich will dich schlagen zum Ritter der Tafelrunde. Willst du dich schlagen? Der Donutrunde. Schlag mich richtig fest. Was meinst du? Nee, das schlag mich richtig fest. Nee, es ist nur eine symbolische ... Ja, ja, aber hau gerne so richtig fest.
Es ist nur eine symbolische Gister, dass ich dich jederzeit töten könnte.
Ja, schlagt mich nicht so einfach.
Irgendwie fühlt sich das nicht richtig an.
Schlagt mich so richtig doll.
Nein, also es ist nur ein Antippen.
Ja, tipp mal hart.
Nee, es ist nur ein ...
Oh, nee, mach mal richtig.
Nee, es ist einfach nur ein Ritual.
Und ihr wundert, ich wundere mich, warum ich mich noch nie gefragt habe, ob ich Teil nach der Hafer-Runde sein soll. Ja, I don't know, aber man kann, das ist der einzige Weg, der mir einfällt, um Tische grösser zu machen, wäre ein anderer Tisch, der Donut-shaped ist, darum zu machen. Es ist eine gute Idee, es ist keine schlechte Idee, vor allem wenn du erstmal einen Donut hast, dann kannst du, ja, ist nicht schlecht. Richtig schwierig eigentlich, ne? Du kannst dir dann oval draus machen, es gibt ja diese Klapptische. Das stimmt, ja. Wo man immer denkt, so, oh, dann kann ich das aufklappen, wenn noch mehr Leute kommen. Hat noch nie jemand gemacht. Doch, das stimmt nicht. Doch, das stimmt nicht. Nein, das stimmt nicht. Weil vor allem, du musst dir ja einfach ... Ich stehe mir immer so vor. Weil es gibt ja so runde Tische, die kannst du dann so aufklappen und dann hast du da mehr Platz. Aber ich denke mir so, während du das während der Party machst, fallen ja alle Sachen von dem Tisch runter. Es ist einfach komplett wie zusammengeklappt. Ich stelle mir nur vor, der Typ, der so richtig stolz auf diesen Tisch ist und sagt so, wir können ihn auch aufklappen, wir können ihn jederzeit aufklappen, wir können jederzeit aufklappen, wenn sich noch einer hinsetzt, können wir jederzeit aufklappen, okay, setz dich hin, okay, kein Problem. und einfach alle Teller fallen runter, der Truthahn, alles fliegt durch, einfach grösser, ohne weiteres, perfekt grösser. Aber ich finde auch lustig, dass du denkst, der wäre, falls eine Party spontan eskaliert, oder spontan kommen noch Leute, und dann glaubt man, nein, die Idee ist, du hast sonst immer einen kleinen Tisch für deine Familiensituation, wo du mit deiner Frau da sitzt und die Frau sagt, ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf deinen Scheiss, die ganze Zeit sagt sie das und dann sagt, ja okay, wir können mal wieder Leute einladen, sie sagt, ja okay, wow, lad da die ganzen Freunde ein, die sind auch alle so mega, Schatz, ich liebe dich, ja, cool, mich, so wie du den Frederik auch lieb hast neulich, ne? Da habe ich euch wieder Leute gesehen.
Wenn spontan Leute kommen, können wir das jederzeit ändern.
Ich mag solche Konzepte, die immer auf dieses,
auch so diese Übergangsjacke oder diese man schneidet sich die Ärmel ab-Jacke,
ich könnte jederzeit die Ärmel jetzt abnehmen.
Wenn es jetzt plötzlich, wenn es plötzlich wärmer wird,
ich könnte die Ärmel abnehmen.
Die Möglichkeit ist total geil zu haben.
Und du denkst dir, warum wird es nicht wärmer?
Ja, genau.
Komm, können wir nicht mehr, können wir nicht heißen?
Der Tisch ist dafür da, den macht man dann grösser, wenn du weisst, wir kriegen heute Gäste. Wir finden die Frage, dass die Frage, die die Frage, die die Frage, die die Frage, die die Frage. Dann warst du noch nicht auf meiner Party. Weisst du nicht, wer am Ende kommt und nicht kommt, du weisst auch nicht, was passiert, weil wir sagen immer yes and zu allem und also
crazy,
crazy, was da passiert,
keine Ahnung, wirklich, selbst wenn du sagst,
du kommst zur Party, du hast keine Ahnung.
Mario Kart zu dritt, weil nicht mal viel
und der vierte Controller ist leer, also der
bleibt halt an der Startlinie stehen, weil wir
wissen nicht, wie man die Anzahl der Spieler ändert,
es ist immer auf vier und dann bleibt eine immer an der Startlinie stehen.
Einfach die beiden Köpfe gleichzeitig drücken, einfach.
Ach so, aber wir haben immer einen an der Startlinie, immer Luigi allein an der Startlinie. Nee, ich musste nicht. Oder manchmal, wenn man umrundet, dann dotzen wir den manchmal so an. Winkt ihr dem zu? Ja, aber es sind viele Leute nicht gekommen, tatsächlich. Wir haben echt eigentlich neun Leute eingeladen. Okay. Da kam irgendwie. Nee, vielleicht liegt es ein bisschen daran, dass ihr dann ... Wir mussten dann den Tisch wieder kleiner machen, weil nicht genug Leute gekommen sind. Oh, das finde ich auch gut, wenn der Tisch kleiner macht, damit es unangenehmer ist. Kommt niemand mehr? Dann brauchen wir gar nicht so einen grossen Tisch. Ist ihm der Tisch zu unangenehm gross, dann nehmt jetzt den Clubmeister dreitausend. Ihr könnt ihn nicht nur viel grösser machen, falls mehr Leute kommen zu ihrer privaten Tafelrunde, nein, sie können ihn auch viel kleiner machen. Nehmen sie einfach immer mehr Ringe, ist das einfach so ein Ringtisch? Nehmen sie einfach Ringe weg und irgendwann hat man so einen ganz kleinen Tisch. Nur zu zweit, sie wollen mit ihrem Date ein bisschen enger beisammensitzen, dann machen sie ihn noch kleiner. Die meisten von ihren Freunden sind nicht zu ihrer Party erschienen, kein Problem. Zieluser. Und dann wird einfach so wieder alle Teller zermalmt, einfach so. Dann sieht man so einen Set-Heavy, der so mega sauer ist. Es sind nicht alle Gäste erschienen. Und dann macht er so wütend, fammelt er an dem Tisch rum. Kein Problem. Aber wir haben das Problem nie. Wir haben einen Tisch, wir sind immer nur zu zweit. Wir waren mal mehr, wir waren mal mehr. Das stimmt, wir waren mal mehr. Mal gucken, vielleicht nächste Woche haben wir wieder ein paar Leute dabei oder so. Einfach ein paar Jungs, ein paar Mädels, einfach ein paar Leute. Und ihr habt schon gemerkt, wir haben eine kleine Neuigkeit, denn es gibt ab sofort das Podcast-UFO auch mit Videocontent. Checkt dafür einfach mal unsere Instagram-Seite aus, generell unsere Social-Media-Plattform. Und neu sind wir auch bei TikTok, da könnt ihr uns folgen. Da gibt's ab und zu jetzt Videos von uns. Regelmäßig pro Woche findet ihr da Snippets aus dem Podcast. Und das Coolste überhaupt, ich find das sehr cool, bin sehr stolz darauf, dass wir es hingekriegt haben, wir geben euch ab sofort für alle, allen Patreon Unterstützern von euch, für alle Clubmitglieder, alle Clubmitglieder des Ufo-Clubs, ihr bekommt einen Videopodcast, also die ganze Folge als Videocast online bei Patreon, wenn ihr da auch Bock drauf habt, dann checkt doch mal unser Patreon-Angebot aus. Also wir haben 10% auf Merch. Guckt das alles nochmal nach jetzt. Ja, das stimmt. Wir haben 10% auf Merch, ihr bekommt die Folge einen Tag eher, sie ist werbefrei und jetzt auch noch als Videopodcast. Wenn das was für euch ist, dann checkt mal aus, patreon.com slash das Podcast-UFO. Nur für mich, kann Stefan mal die Hand heben, bitte? Hm? Von uns beiden. Du bist Stefan. Ich bin Stefan, ja. Ich bin der andere, ich bin Florentin. Ah, okay. Einfach, dass das mal klar ist, falls man das noch nie gesehen hat. Stefan? Jo. Du? Genau, also inzwischen 28 Jahre alt, aus Köln, geboren aber eigentlich in Cham, das ist im Ruhrgebiet bei Dortmund. Genau, ich mache das Podcast-U-UFO seit inzwischen sieben Jahren. Ja, ich bin Florentin, ich bin großer Fan von Chips mit Barbecue und Senfgeschmack, mag lange Spaziergänge am Rhein, und, ja, mein Abfluss ist kaputt. Und dann immer wichtig, man endet immer auf und, ja, ja. Und dann, genau. Genau. Ja, alles klar. Also schaut mal vorbei, patreon.com slash das Podcast UFO für alle Clubmitglieder. Wir haben so viel Spaß im Club, Leute. Und wir lachen auch über die, die nicht im Club sind. Ansonsten sehen wir uns nächste Woche wieder. Bis dahin wünsche ich dir einen ganz, ganz schönen Tag und eine ganz, ganz schöne Woche. Ja, okay. Ich dachte gerade, das bleibt bei einem Tag. Ich wünsche euch drei gute Tage.
Ich wünsche euch drei gute Tage.
Drei gute Tage.
Und den Rest lauft in euer Überleben, ich sag's euch.
Haut rein, macht's gut, wir heben langsam ab.
It's a worst bird production.